over the last month or so I have much
like Jesus suffer for the sins of
mankind week in and week out stopping
myself to a chair taping my eyes open
burning a lifelong image of Dragon Ball
GT into my retinas that no amount of
bleach could ever dare remove okay maybe
it's a slight exaggeration or am I being
completely unfair here was my time spent
watching Dragon Ball GT as bad as I
anticipated or many claimed surely not
after all there's a substantial fan base
for Dragon Ball GT online that defends
the show of vehement but which is it it
can't be the worst thing to have ever
happened to Dragon Ball that doesn't
exist while also being a show that's
quite good can it today I'm going to
give my final verdict in a series that
has more detractors in the last
airbenders movie while still maintaining
a massive fan base that will defend it
to its last days having now seen the
entire show from beginning to end I will
be examining exposing and expressing my
opinions on the parts that I hate it and
loved within the crazy confusing and
captivating grandeur that would
ultimately become toy animations final
outing with the Dragon Ball property for
many many years to come this is my final
and complete review for Dragon Ball GT
[Music]
in an effort to be fair here in my final
interview of the show as a whole I will
be looking at and praising the parts I
thought worked and criticizing the
aspects I thought didn't work using
these as the basis for my final personal
verdict at the end got it so here's the
stuff I liked the themes of Dragon Ball
GT steam song might be my absolute
favorite opening theme for any product
ever
never mind Dragonball in general I
enjoyed supers openings for the most
part and I loved chala head-cha-la as
much the next person but gee T's theme
song got me pumped to go on a galactic
search for some Dragon Balls the visuals
in the opening capture exactly what I
wish this show felt like while watching
full of heart adventure excitement and
mystery and after having wrapped up work
the other day something remarkable
happened and strangely enough it
involved Dragon Ball GT I was driving my
best friend and his new wife whom he met
in Japan to the city she doesn't speak
perfect English just yet and I'd imagine
finding a way to participate in
conversation is quite difficult after
bit the car felt quiet and because I've
been living breathing and sleeping
Dragon Ball GT for the last month or so
I began humming its theme song no more
than two seconds into it she joins in
and starts singing the words along with
me which to my surprise I was able to
join it on to I mean give me a break
I've listened to the song like a million
times this month that connection was
important and it gave us a window into
talking about manga and anime for the
next few hours so in a way without GT I
wouldn't have had that moving on to the
show proper I appreciated and noticed
right from the beginning of the second
arc that despite their not being much
similar in terms of tone from Dragon
Ball Z Dragon Ball GT did make a
concerted effort to link every arc
together in one way or another this
genuinely helped me think of the story
as just that one big long story rather
than individuals smaller segmented ones
this is something a lot of shows fail in
doing but GT did not and it specifically
helped the baby and the shadow dragon
sagas feel like something more speaking
of which the concepts for the baby and
Shadow Dragon sagas were honestly very
appropriate and well chosen for Dragon
Ball the first arc of the series to me
at least didn't feel like a fitting
continuation of the story that Dragon
Ball had left off on Dragon Ball Z had
focused largely on magic and sci-fi
elements and to suddenly switch to
exclusively adventure targeted towards
children felt out of place which is why
wouldn't a be--' turned up returning
dragon ball to a sci-fi atmosphere it
felt very much like a return to form for
me
and most certainly was the writing for
the first 80% of the arc was very tight
with a ton of well executed surprises
and character-driven moments through
Goten mr. Stayton majin buu and even OOP
additionally the shadow dragon saga as a
concept at least is probably the most
fitting final arc I've ever seen
attempted for a show like dragon ball
that really was never conceived with an
ending in mind also I really enjoyed the
motivation pan had to involve herself in
the story at the beginning I found her
desire to prove herself to be compelling
and offered a lot in the way of
opportunity for big moments in the
future so as an isolated decision to
start her character off as that I
thought it was a very well orchestrated
beginning additionally the inclusion of
a sentient dragon ball radar in guru or
guild was something I was very
apprehensive of at the beginning I
thought it could have very easily become
a gimmick and annoying but thankfully I
was wrong and he ended up being the
biggest hero in the series for me in the
looks and aesthetics department I
thought GT was rather consistent at no
point that I noticed did the quality dip
below what we would have come to expect
from Dragon Ball Z additionally once
again from the conceptual Department
Super Saiyan 4s design I thought was
quite interesting at the very least it
fit in perfectly with the baby saga and
it wasn't another blond variation of
Super Saiyan but its own unique thing
that has garnered its own strong
following online and in my experience
this transformations design seems to be
the most memorable attribute in Dragon
Ball GT as a whole and finally of course
I absolutely adored the final episode
with all my heart
the reason I've taken the time to point
out all of what I've enjoyed about the
series is to help those that really did
enjoy this show to understand that
anything I disliked is coming from a
place of me wanting to enjoy the show we
all like and dislike different things
I'm about to explain to you guys
everything I disliked about this series
so let's dive in things I didn't like I
go into excruciating detail as to what I
specifically dislike about Dragon Ball
GT s first-ever arc in this video here
but in short it felt like it didn't know
what it wanted to be totally it felt all
over the place and in terms of pacing it
felt like it was really dragging its
feet kozo Morishita
a producer who worked on Dragon Ball GT
s description of this part of the show
feels turbulent to say the least the
team seemed filled with uncertainty
surrounding the direction of the show
which is why they take a higher turn
into something familiar what
the baby saga almost immediately after
the first arc it's as if the show's
begining was geared exclusively towards
children instead of a mixed demographic
like its predecessor was Super Saiyan
for despite being a massive fan favorite
moment in the show one even I
acknowledged earlier in this video
doesn't feel earned at all to me and
ends up being practically the only form
Goku uses from that point onward
resulting in a scene Goku need to go
Super Saiyan 4 in order to lift
something over his head or to save a
town which honestly to me seems
excessive when you consider turning
Super Saiyan 3 made the earth shake in
other words despite specific power
numbers not mattering in a show like
Dragon Ball an understanding of how
strong someone actually is relative to
another character in the show is very
important the peak of my GT confusion
however came about during the fight with
Shenron at the end in base form Goku is
pushing his blasts back like what and
furthermore how he gets his tail back is
fun and funny and I've mentioned that in
the video prior but it flies in the face
of every form that came before it
great design or not the form has no
journey and I genuinely don't care much
for it because of that in other words I
personally still like regular old Super
Saiyan if it didn't look as cool as it
does simply because of what it
represents in the story and for Super
Saiyan 4 I only care about it because it
looks cool to show that I am being
completely fair hair I equally don't
care at all about Super Saiyan 3 it
comes out of nowhere in the story with
no buildup and doesn't feel earned and
therefore much like Super Saiyan 4 I
don't really care about it because it
doesn't carry any emotional significance
on the action side of things I thought
the action and fights are honestly quite
forgettable I'm able to watch them in
the moment but they're for the vast
majority of the time generic fight
sequences that unlike the main series
really are hurt by the absence of an
Akira Toriyama source manga and while
we're on the topic of boring and generic
super Android 17s arc made absolutely no
sense to me how did dr. gyro and dr. Miu
build another Android in hell what parts
do they use how do they communicate with
Android 17 in the living world without
telepathy or the aid of someone like
King Kai these aren't small nitpicks I
have these are parts of a story that are
left unexplained as if it's not
important display the entire story
hinging on these very plot points white
piccolo
communicate in the afterlife without the
help of someone like King someone
he needed help from prior why King Yemma
moved someone to hell but not out of
hell it seemed ridiculously convenient
why did anyone stay behind in Hell to
fight Goku in the first place alone he
can do just about as much as he did with
Frieza and sell there it felt like their
presence was included only to pad an
already very very short run time and
finally Android 18 and krillen played a
tiny part in the overall story but
ultimately amounted to being the most
interesting part by a country mile they
should have had more to do and to be
honest Dragon Ball GT as a whole just
felt very confusing to me and I think
that confusion can be heard in these
snippets from an interview cause a
Morishita participated in in 2005
although Dragon Ball GT turned Goku back
into a kid which signified returning him
to square one story wise I thought that
not going back was important Dragon Ball
GT was made so as not to drag out Dragon
Ball Z and I supposed it's also because
we were too caught up in creating new
enemies I remember working extremely
hard thinking of what the enemy would do
and what sort of bad people they would
be thinking back in the series now the
enemy characters of Dragon Ball GT have
certain parts that are based off enemies
from Dragon Ball and Dragon Ball Z and
speaking of confusing pan is literally
only there to cause trouble and conflict
exclusively to provide motivation and
cause for Goku and sometimes trunks to
act in a proactive manner to save her
this bothered me for two reasons the
first is obvious as becomes quite
quickly
a tired character contrivance but the
second is a little more under the hood
so to speak the first two episodes that
introduced us to pan are filled with
scenes showing us that she is surrounded
by people that undervalue her as a
capable fighter and defender of the
earth not taken seriously and constantly
treated like a little princess which she
doesn't like that sets up I thought
quite clearly a character arc whereby
she grows to understand what it takes to
be a galactic defender and for her
family to see her and treat her like the
respected warrior she wants to be much
like trunks Vegeta and Goku are but know
time and time again she is shown to be
ignorant to mean insanely childish and
completely wrong I'm pretty sure if I
was to try and count all the times pan
caused the group trouble I'd die of old
age first and this is a particularly
important criticism I think for one big
reason Dragon Ball GT acknowledged and
put large funds in to course-correct in
the direction of the show after the
first arc they wanted to move away from
the episodic self-contained nature of
these episodes they were working on in
order to create more spontaneous and
action filled stories and in keeping
these tired formulas of pen getting into
trouble being the catalyst for action it
just feels like they changed the
wallpaper but not the room the villains
are different and the setting is
different but the motivations to fight
are the exact same which despite their
best efforts only ends up feeling less
spontaneous as a result ironically on
the other side of things trunks sort of
assumes the role bulleted in early
Dragonball being the one that knows how
to use tech that helps the plot move
forward however again because we're
moving from a show that had so many of
its greatest parts from the change and
development of a number of characters
for it to then go to a series where
growth isn't delivered at all it made
the show to me at least feel a lot less
interesting Goku already doesn't change
and to surround him with more static
character arcs just makes for a much
less interesting cast of characters for
Goku to bounce off of furthermore
because the show quickly reverted to an
action sci-fi show on earth halfway
through season two trunks found himself
almost useless as he had to compete for
screen time with the likes of Goten
Gohan and Vegeta all characters that
have either more interesting
personalities or have been established
for much longer in the series this
wouldn't have been an issue had he
demonstrated something unique or
magnificent in the prior episodes but he
really didn't do all that much better
one or two things and so that's large
the reason why in the fourth arc Vegeta
sort of comes out of nowhere to join
koku in the spotlight for the battle
against Shenron Tony must have noticed
that this sort of comes out of nowhere
as they interrupted the fight with Goku
to show an entire flashback episode for
Vegeta as he had up until this point
played a minor role in the show at best
his biggest role being used as a vessel
for baby in two arcs prior where
realistically baby did most of the
talking and finally for the last ever
episode of Dragon Ball GT I have a few
things to say but before I do here's
another short snippet from that
interview with kozo Morishita he said
there were fans who wondered why are you
ruining the original and also those that
thought the ruined parts were what made
it interesting perhaps draggable GT
pushed away some of those who
being fans from the very beginning of
the mangas run however I am certain that
even fans were naysayers will be
convinced if they watched the final
episode of Dragon Ball GT in that very
same interview kozo mentions that from
the very beginning they had agreed of
how the story for Dragon Ball GT would
end which to me begs the question why
does it feel like it only works because
of the original Dragon Ball series
Krillin Vegeta and piccolo get emotional
standoffs in that very episode providing
the majority of the nostalgia from it
yet their contribution to Dragon Ball GT
as a whole was next to nothing now don't
get me wrong the final episode works
exceptionally well but it does so in
spite of Dragon Ball GT and because of
Dragon Ball Z naught because Dragon Ball
GT contributed anything to us they could
have quite literally made that episode
right after Dragon Ball Z and it could
have had the same impact and that says a
lot about what was actually achieved in
Dragon Ball GT I think I understood from
the very moment I sat down to tackle
this month-long project that despite my
best efforts a large portion of people
would undoubtedly leave having just
watched this series unfulfilled and
disappointed with what I had to say
about it not necessarily because I
didn't put an adequate amount of care or
effort into these videos but because
their voice wasn't heard or reflected
upon in my final thoughts the very fact
that that is true is proof of one thing
to me that no matter how much anyone
studies writing attempts to empathize
and understand the viewpoints of others
or rewrites Draft after draft of a
script a full comprehensive
understanding of Dragon Ball is
impossible and I think that's what makes
it so successful across almost every
single culture on this planet I can
begin humming the tune of Dragon Ball GT
around my best friend's new wife and she
can finish the melody from memory
despite us not being able to communicate
seamlessly yet I can run into a random
Colombian family on vacation and explain
to them what I do for a living they can
get excited because they have fond
memories of this show the odds of
everyone liking and disliking the same
things about a particular piece of ours
are astronomical
they think that's okay to me these are
the reasons I personally didn't connect
with Dragon Ball GT but if you did I
totally respect them kind of love that
because to me at least it emphasizes
what is perhaps the most elusive and
magical quality of dragon ball its
ability to bring joy in the most
unlikely of ways to the most unlikely of
places so if you enjoy Dragon Ball GT
that's awesome I hope you guys enjoyed
this series and until next time thank
you so much for watching